I think babies become a hybrid of the
parents I think that she has some of my
ways and she has some of them others
ways as well I think that's the best way
for it to be the guy and his wife tiny
welcomed their seventh child heiress
Diana Harris in March the pregnancy was
a surprise I didn't believe and cameras
from the couple's reality show the
family hustle were there to capture
their journey everyone was extremely
pleased I think major when he found out
it was going to be a girl I think he
wanted a little brother but he loves and
you know and now that she's here he
definitely appreciates it her name eros
Harris the same befitting I mean all my
children have regal names and she should
be no different
well tamika's mom is named Diana and
also she was born on down to Ross's
birthday the kid's diaper duty or
anything like that
I mean if necessary you know it's not
isn't that mandatory but they're
definitely there to jump in all hands on
deck you know are you starting to your
personality a little bit a little bit a
little bit she likes music
she likes Prince I play some Aaliyah I
have the brothers you know really like
the classics you know things that I will
consider classic I wouldn't want to put
anything trendy in her ear cuz you never
know if it's gonna if it's gonna stick
around long enough
to actually you know gravitate to it